here's a guy who's a stud of stats you
Eagle Scout got the voice Got The Look
got the height you know is gone around
the world you've done good for yourself
I am sure you've had tens of thousands
of options to say yes what was your
processing and I've read the articles on
you to see what you know when you
explain why you didn't but what was
there a moment where you're like yeah
I'm just not gonna do it I don't think I
want to get married I don't want to have
kids what was that conversation like
Jesus that's a lot man but let me start
by saying that
um again I think the first thing we said
when we sat down was you can assign any
meaning you want to anything that
happens and so for me uh I was
surrounded by perfect examples of the
institution working ideally never mind I
understand I mean in general I like a
lot of what you said and some of it I
thought was crazy town I just dismissed
it I I have no problem taking you know
the the stuff that I think is useful in
dismissing the things that don't work
for me
um but
my mom and dad
in fact when I leave here I'm going up
to Baltimore they're celebrating their
60 second wedding anniversary tomorrow
wow the day after my dad turns 90. okay
they've been in love for 63 years that's
crazy right it's great now it gets
crazier than that I grew up on a little
farm in Northern Baltimore County and
next to us was another couple Carl and
Thelma Noble they happen to be my
grandparents and they were madly in love
till the day they died is this the
grandfather that influenced you to be an
eagle scout and build a bridge same one
okay correct uh and so I had a mom and
dad who walked the walk and talked to
talk and so I knew exactly what that
sort of marriage and relationship look
like and next door
I had this other example this beautiful
marriage of these beautiful people and
so I there was never any doubt in my
mind that this is a great institution I
did have some doubts as to whether or
not I could measure up
and so the meaning I assigned to it was
look if if it happens it'll happen if
you're going to make it happen if you're
going to force it to happen because you
because you're coming from some sort of
place where it's been written in the
stars that this is what you ought to do
well then you can make that happen too
but I just didn't want to I just didn't
want to force it and so for a a whole
bunch of weird reasons the various
relationships I've had combined with the
trajectory of my career
I I really kind of step back from all of
it and said I'm not I'm not going to
abdicate my responsibility in making
choices but I do not have a plan I'm not
writing this down this is not step one
step two step three I want it to be
I wanted to be conscious about what I
was doing and about the choices I was
making but I also wanted to be a little
bit of that feather in the beginning of
Forrest Gump just kind of like well
let's see where it goes because to me
the world is is big and interesting and
you know people who are certain about
what they want to do and write books
about how to achieve all of those things
that's cool that's interesting Ayn Rand
did that you know her whole she she
created a philosophy about this whole
thing so you know I in the end
just decided I was going to take my cue
from the next day and play the cards I
got as best I could and it served me
pretty well professionally and
personally frankly you you you you don't
think
um
uh you know like sometimes we sit there
and we're like well you know you know
what would happen if I would have
actually taken School seriously become a
lawyer well you know you're pretty good
at debate what kind of a lawyer would
you have been would you been running a
law firm well no it kind of worked out
for you so stop talking about what if
you would have done this life's been
okay with you getting into the insurance
industry which you know you did okay
there well what if it is what if that
you seem like a very uh deep value uh
meaning of a life contribution
understanding like you're the kind of
guy that if we had dinner with I would
just want to sit there and you talk 99
of the time telling stories I'm probably
gonna walk away learning so much from
you there's a lot of depth uh well
thanks depth in you and it's just felt
it's not even like this isn't like a you
know I'm complimenting to compliment
it's felt and I'm not the only one it's
very natural it just comes out of you
right do you sit there and you say you
know like you know the Jewish proverb
I'm sitting on like dude I I just want
to I just wanna I enjoy I'm the guy that
goes to movies by myself and I enjoy it
I'm telling you because I I would go to
movies I'd say to my assistant uh I got
an appointment to run okay and as you
come where were you at she said I had an
appointment why you have popcorn on your
top like well you know I had an
appointment I told you an appointment
and I would watch movies with uh Anne an
85 year old woman at 10 o'clock in the
morning you know and these people would
be lined up hey Patrick what are we
gonna watch today I'm like I don't know
whatever let's just go sit there and
watch a movie so I enjoy my own company
but then I read this Jewish proverb you
know three things man should do you know
plant a tree which I haven't done yet
but very disappointing yeah
um number two on the most dangerous
listings I'm gonna stay away from that
nobody talks about when it falls on your
house right so plant a tree the other
one is what write a book and then you
know have a son right because it
continues and you're able to do that do
you sit there and you say man I got so
much to offer you know what would it
look like and by the way you're living
at a time where I'm sure you could have
a kid or two or three I think some
people we know have kids in their
mid-60s do you think about there and say
maybe you know it'd be kind of cool
because at a time like this where we're
seeing some troubled teenagers what
statistics of a bad father or you know
not even a bad father somebody that's
not even in the picture what that
impacts what could a you know micro
raise [ __ ] I mean that that that kid is
gonna be a positive net positive to
society do you think about that at all
no not much really not much I used to a
little bit but you just can't know that
by the way if you're sitting in a
theater
by yourself you're not alone
you're there with the film you're there
with the people on the screen and uh and
that can mean as much to you as you want
it to I get lost in movies I get lost in
books and and I like being lost in those
things because I don't like to be alone
I like to be by myself
but I like to be alone right so the
movie is a powerful metaphor it's my
first job the first paycheck I ever got
was a projectionist for United Artists
actually it was for an usher then it was
for a concessionaire then it was for a
cashier then it was for appellationist I
was still in high school I was uh I
started there when I was 17. huh and um
yeah two dollars ten cents minimum wage
1978. but um I'm sorry what was the
other part the whole question about the
fact that you sit there saying hey you
know the kid part just purely the kid
part by the way to me it's not even
marriage it's purely the kid part yeah
so
foreign
my Foundation
has helped 1700 kids at this point
getting scholarships to weld and
plumbing and steam fitting pipe fitting
and so forth and so on
um I'm not saying that that's the same
as having a kid it's not it's not even
close but the I think the reason having
a son is on that checklist that you just
went down is because
because a man ought to be able to see
the needle move a man ought to be able
to see
an impact on on another man a boy you
know you you want to be able to make a
difference you want to think that your
ideas and your beliefs and your words
and your Deeds can help shape something
and so that is not something I'm willing
to to give up but I really wonder you
know uh I mean
Gerald Ford
was adopted you know the president of
the United States had one of the one of
the worst fathers you could possibly
have and uh his mom Dorothy uh finally
got out of there and the paint salesman
who married his mom
uh his name was Gerald Ford he he gave
the boy his name and he raised him
like a man ought to raise a son and if
you ever read what what Gerald Ford went
on to say about his adoptive father
versus his actual father then you're
left with no choice
but to ask what what is the real
relevance of the DNA what is the real
impact I mean
I just don't think there's ever
I don't think there's a better example
of an easy thing juxtaposed with a hard
thing how easy is it to slip it in there
have the kid how easy it is it to to
make a woman pregnant and how hard is it
no question about how hard is it right
yeah for the next 18 20 or you've asked
my dad today he'd say yeah man he's
still my dad 60 years later he's still
he's still being a dad so yeah having a
kid peacek toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]